j'ai des infos toutes fraîches toutes
belles si on laisse mec alors sur le
petit modèle
[Musique]
j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour tous ceux
et toutes celles et je remonte un peu le
museau qui veulent un excellent
photophone excellent smartphone pas
forcément trop cher il ya beaucoup de
monde dans le milieu de gamme bio si
beaucoup de monde dans le haut de gamme
vous me direct et justement c'est cool
parce que google a sorti l'année
dernière si pas si vous vous souvenez
c'est google pixels 3 et pixel 3xl ses
smartphones l' excellent smartphone en
termes de photos surtout vraiment
excellent très bonne expérience logiciel
surtout si vous êtes client de google et
que vous avez un compte google et que
vous utilisez gmail maps et compagnie
c'est extrêmement bien optimisé ça c'est
vraiment vraiment bien très bon
smartphone d'ailleurs si vous ne les
connaissez pas je vous invite à les
visionner mon test qui doit s'afficher
ne sais pas si c'est là on va dire ah je
tente là par hasard à aller visionner
montaise qui vous parle justement de ces
smartphones donc là c'est vraiment
vraiment cool est justement très bonne
nouvelle
google pourrait sortir à cette année en
milieu d'année deux nouvelles versions
se fixe à 3 pixels 3 à pixel 3 à ixelles
qui serait de smartphone milieu de gamme
qui proposerait sensiblement la même
chose que ces deux belles bêtes là mais
forcément moins puissantes moins cher
mais toujours très intéressant on va se
faire un petit peu déjà un petit tour un
peu du marché pour comprendre un peu
comment ça marche parce que je suppose
que vous êtes consommateur de
smartphones comme je dirais globalement
quasiment tout le monde et le milieu du
smartphone c'est un milieu qui est
extrêmement compliqué parce qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'acteurs sur
le marché un milieu extrêmement
concurrentiel qu'il le devient davantage
avec notamment l'arrivée depuis quelques
temps des constructeurs chinois
il ya beaucoup d'offres beaucoup de
produits c'est vachement bien pour le
consommateur c'est beaucoup plus dur
pour les constructeurs et google
également là parce que google avec cette
salle 3 ticks à 3 xl à deux smartphones
qui sont vraiment excellents mais sont
pas forcément les smartphones qui vont
avoir le plus de succès qui vaut mieux
se vendre et pourtant derrière vous avez
une boîte comme google donc c'est des
fois un petit peu compliqué à comprendre
des smartphones qui peut-être un look un
petit peu old school qui peut des fois
leur être reproché d'avoir une grande
bande noire en rond noir en bas ou en
espèces des normands coche pour le pixel
3xl ça ça leur fait un peu défaut par
contre les produits sont vraiment
vraiment vraiment intéressant et google
ces digues a écouté a priori on va
continuer notre révolution dans le monde
des smartphones mais cette passion
s'attaquer au segment du milieu de gamme
et ça c'est plutôt intéressant parce que
pour toutes les personnes qui veulent un
bon smartphone un bon photophone mais
qui n'ont pas envie de mettre trop
d'argent et qui aiment la barre google a
un vrai sens il ya donc une info qui a
fuité qui vient du site night to five
google qui a vu justement sur le site us
de google apparaître le terme google
pixels 3 a égalemen comme de protection
pour le pixel 3 a appris aux ça serait
une une erreur de manip de la part de
google est probablement quelqu'un qui
aurait appuyé un peu trop rapidement sur
le bouton publier ça a été vu entre tan
tan pis voilà
bref ça nous permet de nous en tout cas
d'avoir cette information est de marquer
les nouveaux smartphones qui vont
arriver
j'ai des infos toutes fraîches toute
belle sur les specs alors sur le petit
modèle ça devrait ressembler un petit
peu à son grand frère
google puisque seuls trois sur le pixel
3 house va voir d'écran de 5,6 pouces un
écran oled
enfin c'est vachement cool avec une
résolution de 2220 par 1080 pixels fhd
plus tandis que sur le grand modèle on
aurait un écran de 6 pouces toujours
bien évidemment vous en douterez du oled
et on aurait une résolution de 2160
parmi les 80 pixels ils auraient tous
les deux un snapdragon 6 ans et un
processeur milieu de gamme de chez
qualcomm mais qui rassurez vous fait
franchement bien la faire c'est sûr par
rapport aux 845 qui vont équiper ses
smartphones là où 1 855 qui est
aujourd'hui le socle plus haut de gamme
on va pas aller aussi loin capacités de
calcul
mais bon dans l'absolu 1 670 vachement
bien la faire vous aurez en plus 4 gigas
de ram 64 gigas
de stockage et une batterie 3000 vies
antérieures alors pour élire trois mille
billions terreur c'était un petit peu
limite rassurez vous passiez une vraie
belle optimisation logiciel qui fait par
google c'est quand même leur encore de
métier le logiciel à google dont deux
points de vue là ça devrait franchement
le faire et très bien évidemment sur un
android 9 pas comme ses grands frères et
ils auraient une seule caméra à
l'arrière c'est un petit peu la donne de
ces smartphones une seule caméra ici de
12 mégapixels une fois de plus je ne
sais pas si vous avez vu les tests de
ces smartphones là mais avec une seule
caméra comme ça ces smartphones font un
boulot extraordinaire et ça devrait être
sensiblement la même chose avec cette
pixels 3 et pixel 3xl ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est que google
avait été annoncé comme être en
difficulté dans le segment des
smartphones je vais pas dire vous pour
commencer est ce que vous avez un
smartphone de google pixels 3 et que ces
3 x est peut-être un pixel 2 vous aviez
eu en import et si c'est pas le cas dans
votre entourage
combien de personnes ont un smartphone
de google à mon avis c'est pas énorme
élan ne suis pas sûr que ce soit un
smartphone qui soit énormément vendu de
course disait bon c'est un petit peu
compliqué pour google est ce qu'ils vont
continuer sur les smartphones est ce
qu'on va avoir un pixel 4
a priori on aurait pu que c'est le cas
qu'il doit arriver mais dans la deuxième
partie de l'année donc on en reparlera
ultérieurement d'ailleurs chose invite à
vous abonner dès aujourd'hui pour tout
savoir et tout de suite de l'acte uteq
et notamment de ses jolies petites bêtes
là et ce qui est cool en tout cas c'est
de voir que google effectivement même si
on ne sont pas forcément les smartphones
les plus vendus continue à rester sur
place continuent à faire de belles
propositions et notamment dans le milieu
de gamme donc j'ai vraiment hâte de voir
ça dès qu'ils sortiront bien évidemment
on ira les rencontrer on les prendra en
main on les testerins peu tous les côtés
et on fera de belles photos vous invite
donc une fois de plus à vous abonner
comme ça vous serez tous à ce moment là
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
trouvez ça intéressant est ce que vous
avez hâte oui non pas du tout est ce que
vous aimez ces pixels 3 est ce que
vous pourriez être tenté par un pixel 3
à lui fait de vous dire bon mois les
pics à trois je les trouvais pas mal d
émettre plus de 800 euros sur un
smartphone google
bah je sais pas j'ai peut-être pas envie
maintenant si vous êtes sur un
smartphone puissant autour de 500 600
euros est-ce que c'est plutôt quelque
chose qui vous conviendrait comment
est-ce que vous situeriez par rapport à
tout ça je vous invite à marquer tout ça
bien évidemment en commentaire curieux
de voir tout ce que vous avez à dire sur
ce je vous embrasse vous donne rendez
vous dès demain
et puis moi ils s'attendaient m'amuse
avec ce petit smartphone parce que je
trouve très intéressant vous embrasse
châu